>>Student: I run the Washington Post.
>>Student: I ran for President.
>>Student: I lobby Congress.
>>Amber: We had one student in
my former district who dropped
out of high school and came
to AP Government every day
till the end of the year.
And he called himself the worst
drop-out in the history of drop-outs,
because he still showed up.
I don't know why he came.
But I do! I do know why.
Because there was a role for him.
And he played a part in the
classroom learning experience.
For him to drop out of high school,
but still to come to that class,
that was the moment
in that first year
that changed the way I
thought about the course.
>>Walter: What we're
working on in the Knowledge
in Action project is a way of making
advanced high school course work
accessible to more and more children,
and worth it, by making it a deep,
rich curriculum that they can
take with them into the future.
>>Student: Do we want to say
before or against the Alabama law?
>>Student: Our interest group would
be before this, before the Alabama,
because all it is is collecting data.
>>Student: It's hard to collect data
when people are not forthcoming.
It makes it really hard
to get accurate data.
>>Walter: The way we attempt
to achieve deep conceptual
learning is primarily
through a particular kind of
rigorous project-based learning.
It's not uncommon in an AP
course to have a project or two.
We're trying to drive the course
through projects, which is to say,
through experiential learning.
>>Student: Two-thousand
students stopped going to school.
Alabama school systems are going to
fall apart, because there's not going
to be government funding.
>>Student: Two-thousand students
in a state that probably has what?
Ten to thirteen million,
somewhere in there?
>>Student: How many of those
thirteen million go to school?
>>Adrienne: Well, AP Gov is a class
that has traditionally been
taught in one semester.
So in one semester they fly through
all the institutions of government,
as well as how they're
linked together,
and how they're linked to the people.
And it has traditionally been
a very lecture-oriented course,
because it's a lot of content to get
through, and not a whole lot of time.
The idea came of, "Well, could we
make an entire course in government
that really is about how we put kids
in the middle of these situations,
and not how we just tell
kids about these situations."
>>Student: These people that are here
illegally, if they're here legally,
if we make it possible for
them to get a Green Card,
they'll then in turn be paying taxes.
They'll be benefiting our
society instead of hurting it.
>>Lise: I came onboard
after the AP US Government
and Politics course was in place.
And the team wanted to add a second
course, AP Environmental Science.
>>Student: So the one
percent, where's one percent?
>>Student: Only four
of them are living.
>>Walter: Everybody understands all
of these brilliant hard-working
teachers that teach AP know
that what they need to
deliver is a large proportion
of their students passing that test.
So the most direct route to doing
that is to teach to the test.
Well, what we're trying
to do is figure out a way
to drive more learning
into that course.
So in our courses, students are
very often involved in a simulation.
In the case of the AP Gov
course, they're taking the role
of a Supreme Court Justice,
or somebody running a
campaign, or running for office.
>>Asher: It's not communistic.
What he wants to do is reinforce--
>>Anna: Sharing the wealth among
the people who didn't earn it?
>>Asher: He wants to reinforce
the already existing programs,
such as Social Security.
All we're doing is strengthening
the social safety net,
so that we can have free
trade that's also fair trade.
>>Mariama: Sometimes you lose
the sense of you're in a role,
you're not actually
really that person.
But sometimes you become that
person without even realizing it.
>>Amber: So it's different
than any kind of class
where you would just have a lecture,
do a worksheet or an activity,
maybe make a poster at
the end, and take a test.
This is structured
completely differently.
So that from the very
beginning students have a role
that they play, and a need to know.
>>Jerry: All these
activities are a way for kids
to get personally invested in
the project, often with the goal
of winning, or coming out ahead.
Especially kids who are not
already the ones really well-suited
for traditional AP format classes.
>>Lise: One of the
key design principles
in the course is this
idea of looping.
>>Amber: We ask students constantly
to go back and think about,
"What did it mean when you were
this, or when you played this role?
And what does it mean
now in this situation?"
So we try to get them
to make connections,
by never leaving behind the
unit that we taught in the past.
>>Caitlyn: A typical class
is just a lot of note-taking,
and a lot of reading from chapters,
and then reiterating
it back to the teacher.
But here you get to
apply it in your life,
and then apply it throughout
the year.
And not just on one
test or one essay.
That's what makes this
class different.
>>Adrienne: All right,
nice job, Nice job.
>>Lise: I think the biggest challenge
with the curriculum is scaling it
to a range of school environments.
Making it work for urban students
in poverty-impacted schools,
and also making it work
for more affluent students.
So we've tried to select problems
in each of the units in the course
that can be adapted to
different environments.
For example, the project
about looking
at one family's impact
on the environment.
That's relevant regardless
of the environment you're in.
>>Student: You're going to measure
the amount of recycled material.
That's one thing we can measure.
>>Student: But how would you do
this if you live in apartment?
We all live in an apartment.
>>Student: Don't you guys
have like a recycling--
like a box, like next to the garbage?
>>Amber: We started the curriculum
In the Bellevue School District.
And the Bellevue School District is
a suburban school district located
right outside the City of Seattle.
Bellevue has quite a
range of affluence,
but you're looking technically at
a wealthier suburban community.
In 2011, we brought the
curriculum to Des Moines, Iowa.
And the Des Moines Public Schools
has a free and reduced lunch average
about 65 percent district-wide.
So the majority of our students are
in the lower socio-economic class.
When bringing the Knowledge
In Action project
to a poverty-impacted
school district,
you're likely to find challenges,
including student preparedness
for AP course work, reading skills
and reading level,
and teacher readiness.
And so we've needed to
make some changes in order
to provide opportunities
for them to have success.
We don't just want equity of access,
you know, entry into the course.
We want equity of outcomes.
We want our kids in
poverty-impacted schools to be just
as successful as kids in other areas.
>>Sherry: Richshunda
started out as one
of those students that,
"I don't like to read.
I don't want to read.
And I've never picked up a
book, and I don't want to.
And so she went into a reading
strategies course last year."
Richshunda is like the poster
child of a student that didn't
like reading, and now loves to read,
and is now reading advanced
placement college material books.
>>Richshunda: In that class,
like everybody's working,
everybody's talking,
everybody's doing groups,
everybody's just active.
Like you don't even want to
leave the class when you have to.
>>Jerry: This project approach gives
you a chance to engage the students
who might otherwise
sort of sit and hide
and keep a low profile
and not do well.
Their performance is
more clear to see,
and their success shows more clearly.
>>Michael: The problem-based
curriculum that they're using
in the AP Government class
is definitely working.
When you walk in, the students
are speaking, not the teacher.
And so you know that they
are learning the material,
because it's coming
out of their mouth.
>>Lise: It's really
exciting to see students
that may not have traditionally
taken an AP course,
or succeeded in an AP course,
actually connect with the material
in a way that makes them successful
in the AP test, of course,
but more importantly impacts
their lives and the decisions
that they begin to make as
adults and even as young adults.
I think that's really exciting to
feel like you've empowered students
in a way that's going to stay
with them for years to come.
I think that's probably the best part
of being involved in
something like this.